I'm former US Attorney for the District
of Columbia Joe digenova Judicial Watch
president tom Fitton Fox News legal
analyst great Jerry all right Joe it's a
lot to absorb
a lot of information but it's so telling
and sad that this could happen in the
United States of America give us your
general takeaways from the new
information today this is now piling on
in a very big way we are headed toward a
very sad ending for the FBI and senior
DOJ officials McCabe is gone
because ray knows what's in the other
emails and the other text mccabe was
sent packing as a result of christopher
ray being briefed by a number of people
who have access to the investigation
that's underway which is going to lead
to criminal charges against the number
of people what you are seeing coming out
now in the text messages is just the
minimum of what is available now to DOJ
officials as they watch sadly he's gonna
get charged Joe I don't mean
interrupting but who are we talking
about
I believe that several several a hi FBI
officials will be charged criminally and
it is conceivable that some DOJ people
will also be charged criminally what
about James Comey I can't answer that
question because too much of the
information about Comey is filtered
through other people it is clear though
that at the time prior to the election
and subsequent to the election there
were a group of people inside the FBI at
the senior levels on the seventh floor
who decided that they were going to
protect Hillary Clinton they were going
to change 302s and they were going to
make sure that she was testimony
explained they were going to change 302
interview notes they were going to
exonerate Hillary and they were going to
frame Donald Trump it is inescapable no
matter what all these people are saying
at the New York Times and The Washington
Post with their silly editor
they are missing one of the great
corruption stories of American law
enforcement and say it involves the
senior levels of the FBI and it is a
national disgrace one of or the biggest
I would consider this the largest law
enforcement scandal in history for this
reason the activities of McCabe and
others and Bruce or and others were
designed to subvert the Constitution and
a national election the most serious
offense under our Constitution Gregg
Jarrett let's start with the new struck
page text that we have out today and
we're still missing the five crucial
months although they have been recovered
we have a lot more coming that's 50,000
in total so with each new revelation it
gets worse and worse for them it surely
does and one can bicker about the
meaning of some of the vagueness of
these text messages but it's abundantly
clear and today's messages just
reinforced it that there was such
extreme a political bias on the part of
strucken page and personal animus toward
Donald Trump the candidate and then the
president that these two people should
have been nowhere near the investigation
and you know some people have said and
I've watched them on other programs as
well when Muller found out he fired
struck well he was on the Hillary
Clinton case the lead investigator then
he jumped to the Trump Russia case then
he jumped to the Muller case so for two
years how much damage did he do before
he was caught let me ask you about this
and the house intel has said the judge
to provide the FISA transcript hearings
Greg I want to talk about the legality
of all this because we do know that
Lindsey Graham and and Senator Grassley
they got a chance to look at all four
FISA applications that was sort of like
a footnote nobody paid attention to last
night with the unredacted memo that they
had as it relates to the Intel I would
think that we if we ever got a hold of
the FISA Court
they're saying the bulk of information
to to allow this to go forward was based
on this phony Hillary Clinton paid for
Russian government dossier I can only am
and and they withheld all this
information from the court I've got to
believe that court judge has got to be
livid and furious tonight yeah this is
the letter that Devon Nunez has sent
today to the presiding judge of the FISA
Court requesting not one but four
different hearings in any transcripts to
determine the false misrepresentations
of fact that were made allegedly by the
Department of Justice and the FBI during
those hearings I mean if you just look
at the Grassley Graham letter it lays
out a meticulous case of how the court
was misled deceived evidence was
concealed but it may be even worse in
those transcripts Leon Panetta was wrong
when he said well the Intel committee
didn't even interview the judges I Got
News for them they have no authority to
do that but they do have authority as
witnessed by this letter today if you
get their hands on the transcripts of
the hearings before those fights our
judges look let me go to tom Fitton tom
and this whole issue of barack obama
wants to be kept abreast of all of this
and struck in page or preparing what
appears to be talking points with
President Obama Wall Street Journal says
was not about the email investigation
but from earlier comments that I saw
that you made you have your doubts about
that yeah well you pick it's either
about the email investigation or the
Russia investigation either way you see
President Obama being intensely involved
and wanting to know everything about
either the Clinton email investigation
or Russian investigation pick your
poison in terms of presidential
involvement in these sensitive criminal
investigations now I've always wondered
why President Obama has skated really
free from any serious inquiries about
his involvement in the Russia
investigations his knowledge about the
dossier its origins remember he you know
he's the politician too was running the
DNC in part did he know about the
payments of the DNC and Hillary Clinton
and the dossiers used
in the Russia investigations and the
FISA applications did he know about the
dossiers use I would think to justify on
maskings these are questions that I have
to be asked of President Obama this
president is being criminally
investigated about his communications
with the FBI director about a criminal
investigation
why isn't there similar in inquiries
into what President Obama was doing what
about Joe digenova this seems to be some
complicity here now if things weren't
bad enough that Hillary is paying for
Russian would read from the from the
Grassley gram memo Russian government
information to be used in an election to
lie the American people then used as the
bulk of information for a FISA warrant
none of it verified if that's not bad
enough now we have the information looks
like Sid Vicious Blumenthal people at
the Department of State are complicit in
in providing steals some of this phony
information that he then coordinates
with the Clinton campaign to disseminate
to the lazy overpaid so-called
journalists in the media in this country
well here's here's the most important
thing about all of this this shows that
the FBI was bootstrapping all of the
information that it was getting and it
was basically a circular firing squad so
that all the information was based on
the same information that therefore
nothing that was being presented to the
FISA Court was actually verifiable and
let me just say something about Leon
Panetta I saw his comments this weekend
where he condemned Chairman Nunez for
politicizing intelligence what a
disgraceful comment by a former CIA
director Leon Panetta should be ashamed
of himself he's obviously not reading
the papers what's more he obviously has
not read the April 26th 2017 opinion of
the FISA Court in which they accused the
FBI of purposely and illegally and
unconstitutionally leaking FISA 702
information to private contractors which
is a felony you've never heard mr.
Panetta say anything about that you've
never heard mr. Pineda say anything
about any of the conduct of John Brennan
the single most political si
I a director in history and Brennan's
comments this weekend
about all of the stuff that Nunez is
doing ranked among the most disgusting
political comments by any CIA former CIA
director in history well I want to know
a Brennan and clapper I want to know
about the surveillance unmasking leaking
intelligence and their potential
understanding and knowledge of that
we'll find out in weeks and months ahead